how to sound like Steve rice how do you
make music that makes you want to move
but not change your place how can our
experience of time be shaped by the
pulse we feel the goal today is to come
up with the track that to the best of my
ability resembles the musical style of
Steve rice in order to do this we need
to take a very close look at what he
does first of all his music is dominated
by rhythm and percussion rather than
traditional mulatto sysm a minimal set
of notes are used especially in short
self-contained motivic units these are
repeated for lengthy periods of time in
ways that create a strong pulse with
plenty of poly rhythms and odd meters
the harmonic language is largely tonal
in the sense that the polarity between
tonic and dominant is strong but
traditional Cadence's are not used in
their usual manners generally I
gravitate towards dominance sub dominant
simple basic parts of the Western
peculiar Y dominance dominance our
Adonis want to go somewhere motivic
development does not happen in the
conventional sense where ideas and
harmonies are elaborated upon and
transformed in dramatic ways rather tiny
changes in rhythm placement and/or tone
create ripple effects that transform the
flow of the music over a long period of
time this happens in a very seamless
manner
richness of tone and color is achieved
by the frequent doubling of like
instruments such as the use of multiple
mallet instruments or keyboards
[Music]
phasing is a technique found in many of
his works it's what happens when two
sounds that are playing identical
material come in and out of sync due to
minor differences in tempo this
interaction produces a distinct set of
complicated rhythms and textures unlike
many themes such as nature the mystique
and religion that are found in a lot of
traditional classical music the theme
that accompanies many of his works are
of the urban environment
[Music]
samples are frequently used especially
documentary material that is voiced
driven or of city sounds where a couple
of attacks in different pitches
different more sustained horn
very different dad the tempo is set by
this piledriver which is the what you
see driving the metal into the ground
when you're building a very tall
building oftentimes speech samples are
accompanied by pitches that match the
natural inflection of the voice when I
began to write different trains that was
the first time that I used pre-recorded
speaking listen to what people said
wrote down the speech melody and had
musicians in an ensemble play what
somebody was saying by how they were
speaking
[Music]
mother-father anybody else ago I think
people in different countries write
different kinds of music based on their
language Bel Canto
Opera comes out of Italy rock and roll
comes out of America comes out of spoken
American English and English English and
Bel Canto Italian rock and roll French
rock and roll is not very interesting
and it's really based on the speech
melody of the musicians of the whole
gesture of a culture rice powerfully
blends tradition with innovation
however radical he may seem upon first
listen the rhythms Pali rhythms phrasing
as well as arrangement of pitches are
all grounded within core elements of
traditional music the complexity of
certain Pali rhythms and unexpected
harmonic changes are derived from a
unique way of shifting think of a
kaleidoscope how immensely beautiful and
complex patterns emerge from a contained
set of objects behind the mirror and now
here's my arrangement of happy birthday
in the style of steve rice
[Music]
even when you're blowing out amazonica
it's important to keep away is funny the
burning if it isn't happy unbirthday
birthday happy birthday to you if it is
birthday to you the unbirthday if it
isn't a birthday be hung birthday to you
if it isn't having everything thank you
Kevin isn't big do you beiong birthday
that isn't happy unbirthday happy
birthday birthday to you if it isn't if
it isn't the unbirthday birthday to you
happy birthday birthday to you if it
isn't it isn't happy hungry huh birthday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]